Now that we know what vertex form looks like for equations of problems that have
leading coefficients other than 1, let's see if we can get this equation in this
form. We have y equals 3x squared plus 6x minus 10. Now what was that tool we
used before to get equations in vertex form? It was called completing the
square. So that's what we need to do here, complete the square. The process is
going to be slightly different, since we have this 3 present now, instead of a 1
in front of the x squared. But, let's give it a try. Well, the first thing we
did before, when we were starting to complete the square. Was recognize that
this constant over here is probably not the constant we're going to need if we
want a perfect square term on the right hand side of the equation. So we want to
get the constant off the right hand side and onto the left hand side. So if we
do that, what does our equation look like now?